[Music]
hey guys how's it going welcome to my
office this is a virtual reality office
tour and I'm so excited because I've
wanted to do one of these for so long
but this one is super special because
guess what this can follow me you can
follow me this way and I'm going to take
you on a virtual tour of my office so I
basically spend almost all of my time
here if I'm not out shooting the
vlogging or traveling start I guess over
here this is my Mac editing station so
this is my Mac monitor which is
connected to one of eight trashcan Mac's
behind there this is my stack of hard
drives great for traveling this is where
I keep a bunch of dongles a bunch of
cords this is my little amiibo my two
favorite Timmy and Tommy this is one of
my bigger vlogging cameras this is the
ATP but Canon this is my everyday g7x
vlogging camera which I feel like most
bloggers do have and most importantly
has an unboxer you've gotta have a good
unboxing knife so this is my very very
sharp Batman unboxing knife so as we
close over here this is the new MacBook
would touch bar which I just recently
got and I know
I'm eventually going to complete get rid
of the trashcan Mac kind of really cool
monitor for this and really just make
this my home if it isn't already we've
got in here that I use for duty do a lot
of times LG vo in this room but it is
super spacious and you can tell that it
could be a little bit echoey as we move
but this alleviates a lot of that is the
nice little razor Mike that I choose
over here these I put on top of my
volume cameras as you can see over here
this is one each one I use there's
something different depending upon the
situation my prized possession
is down here this contender 64 it's not
even hooked up but it just reminds me of
a time in my life where I first really
discovered my love of video games
although I did have a Nintendo
Entertainment System the NES which I'm
going to bring you over here real quick
this is
little any mini it's the classic
addition so you can play 30 old-school
games that he's also on my prized
possession but as I bring you guys over
here this is why I guess we could call
this the PC gaming station I do a lot of
live streaming over here and when I'm
doing live streams I like to use this
camera and this is my PC this is also
another prized possession this is my
custom pink is my gamertag my Xbox gamer
tag on there ops so beautiful
as you can see here this is my VF VR
headset which is great because we're
doing a VR video right now so it's quite
appropriate you might be wondering what
these speakers are more well if you spin
yourself around directly over there I
have a DJ set so when that's actually
hooked up these are the speakers that go
to that but more about
this is my chair I like to share what
I'm doing my work here are my consoles
I've got Xbox 1s down here this is the
new ps4 Chrome which is incredible and
as we sit around this is where the magic
happens I've got a nice microphone here
and I'll spare you all the details but
basically everything close into here one
sit back here and then for the body
magic
this is also my razor laptop which I
travel with when I travel and game love
it go to home I just got this little guy
so I'm about to set this up here so look
for that unboxing and setup very very
soon and of course my Star Wars lamps
which are on both sides the best part
about all of these lights is they are
completely customizable using muffs way
these lightbulbs these are the hue the
philips lights which i've showed you
guys many times before but i basically
can control all of these lights just
using an app right here you may be
wondering why I have an iPad pro sitting
here actually use my iPad pro quite a
lot when I'm using cameras that don't
pass about screens so I'm able to
monitor the video and see what's
happening this is the DJ set which I'm
currently learning to DJ because my dog
is a DJ and he's coming out with an
album I know it sounds crazy but he's
got some really great beasts so I look
forward to showing you guys that and
maybe you will come see us on
poor so last but not least this is the
unboxing table this is where all of the
unboxing magic happens so this is the
camera that I usually used for the
downward angle is Canon cinema c100 mark
- and this here is also another camera
that I like to use as well this is the
sony a7s mark - I use this a lot you
guys might have seen that this one fell
in the pool when I was in Hawaii and it
was an extremely devastating time in my
life but we replace it we've moved on
and here we are so this my friends is my
office door we've also got some lights
up here are the LED light panels which
are incredible
but this is it my Apple watch is going
off - got my subscribe pillows which you
guys should do subscribe okay bye
you